go back to work with just 99 days to go
until election day a new cbs news
battleground tracker poll shows joe
biden has a 10 point national
advantage over president trump in the
battleground state of michigan he leads
the president by
six points and in nearby ohio the
president is ahead
by just one point both are states the
president won
in 2016. this of course comes during a
turbulent campaign season disrupted by
the pandemic
ed o'keefe explains from washington
with 99 days to go and unable to hold
campaign rallies president trump spent
the weekend golfing and greeting
supporters in new jersey
while former vice president joe biden
made virtual appearances at two
fundraisers we need real leadership
now new cbs news polling shows the
economy health care and the pandemic are
top concerns for voters
neither candidate has an advantage on
fixing the economy but the president
earns poor marks in the fight against
covet 19.
that has become a central part of
biden's message
our president wasn't prepared for this
pandemic mr trump is portraying biden as
a dangerous pick
our entire economy and to our very way
of life
are threatened by biden's plans to
transform our nation and
subjugate our communities in the coming
weeks
several turning points remain in early
august biden is poised to announce his
vice presidential running mate
who he says will be a woman choices
include governors
mayors lawmakers and former obama
administration officials
then there's the conventions no funny
hats bad dancing or balloon drops this
year
democrats are still planning for a
mostly virtual event though biden still
plans to accept the nomination in
milwaukee
after a not so filled arena in tulsa and
surging coronavirus cases in florida
the president last week canceled plans
to hold his convention
in jacksonville another big concern in
the coming weeks
foreign interference the nation's top
counterintelligence official says he's
primarily concerned with china
russia and iran but other countries and
groups could also do harm
to our elections finally there's how you
will cast your ballot
and how your vote will be counted
polling locations could be limited with
less available poll workers due to covet
concerns
and election officials anticipate
historic demand for absentee
ballots from voters unwilling or unable
to vote in person
many states warn they're struggling to
recruit the manpower needed
to quickly count so many paper ballots
so that could lead to scenes like this
one in new york city
where they're still counting thousands
of absentee ballots
from congressional primaries held almost
five
weeks ago so even though there's 99 days
to go until election day in some states
early voting begins 41 days from today
and in each of the states that allow for
absentee balloting of course
there is a deadline some cases it's just
a few days before election day
in some cases it's about two weeks out
gail as we say in television if you want
to vote
best to check your local listings
yes we do say that and every time i keep
hearing 99 days until election day you
know what i think of
99 bottles of beer on the wall listen 99
days is still a whole lot of time in
this campaign
do you see anything that could be the
deciding factors we sit here today
july oh absolutely i mean like we said
you got a vp pick coming you have the
conventions you have probably three
debates in the fall
between the president and joe biden
think of it this way
only about a hundred days ago bernie
sanders was just getting out of the race
and donald trump was still in the lead a
lot can change in 99 days
and can you say anything about the
conventions because that's going to be a
very different picture this year
it is as we said the the president has
canceled the republican
gathering in jacksonville democrats are
still holding an event that is going to
be
much more tv friendly much more virtual
and spread out across the country
biden will accept the nomination he says
in milwaukee but don't be surprised if
others speak
from other cities across the country
all right and we will be there so will
you ed